oh really hot hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans you're watching hot one it's the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings today I'm joined by Ricky Gervais
here's a few Emmys on the shelf a world
tour coming soon and you can catch him
in his new film David Brent life on the
road February 10th on Netflix Ricky
welcome for the show I don't know what
I'm doing if I'm being totally honest
how are you with hot food I listen I
don't know I mean you look less like
you're ready for drive-by and and and
now we've got a go so this is a lot of
costing Charlie Rose and [ __ ] jackass
Ricky in fairness we did extend a little
bit for you this time we're going vegan
wings you know Ricky Gervais you owe me
the best I'm going vegan right along
with you gave him the temple of seitan
it's better Gary the temple of Satan
[Music]
this is the baby one is it but it isn't
easy I think I can do this
nice right that's Pleasant
so I want to start by talking about
David Brent the character yes because
the office is so perfect and so
untouchable that some fans like bristle
at the thought of a spinoff but I think
that one could make the case that David
Brent character is more relevant than
ever it's sort of a proxy for the person
who chases Fame at any cost
has no self-awareness whatsoever yeah I
started writing it before the events of
this year unfolded but it is sort of
about that you know time is a different
beast
now people did their life like an open
wound to be famous they do anything to
be on telly fifteen years ago it's a bit
of a prat and he was showing off and he
was a narcissist but he's an
old-fashioned narcissist he's nothing
like today's master fish like Terminator
one meeting Terminator 2 and yeah we've
got the host of The Apprentice in the
White House who says things like I'd
like to punch him in the face and admit
that it abuses women as Brent can't
compete in this new world okay that was
a bit warm of Michael I mean look at
that right yeah I'm only on two I had to
fight just you because I enjoyed I was
enjoying a little chicken wing there
speaking of life on the road you're
preparing this is terrible as well as
already hot well I said too much no no
no Ricky hmm so going which means that
you'll spend a good chunk of 2017 in
hotel rooms and one of my favorite
things about you is your ability to
complain and bellyache on just about
anything
where do five-star hotels fall short
they're too far from the venue sometimes
sometimes I have to travel up to 35
minutes to get to the five style town so
well I've changed the town before if the
five the hotel is too far away
yes let's let your breath
[Music]
oh my god that woman oh god I am such a
[ __ ] wimp okay why are you look at
you you're kind of yoked in this v-neck
[Music]
and the tongue is burning a little bit
but that one sort of filled my mouth a
bit more I think I don't too much of
that that one okay that one's got its
got some in lips as well it's moved it's
moving I didn't touch my lips I don't
know how it got there
so by osmosis this one has gone from my
tongue it's gone down my throat to my
feet up and to my lips
somehow oh it's got my throat as well
now oh we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain there Graham and
what we do is we do a deep dive on our
guest Instagram we pull interesting
pictures that we think need more context
but with you you have sort of a theme
and I need to know everything I can
about the bath selfie I'm part aquatic I
stay in the bath for about 25 minutes
and now with the iPhone I've got a
computer in the bathroom so I do stuff
in it as a lot richer and my baths got
deeper and my testicles started to
extend with age I discovered the
testicles float so yeah you're three on
the water how do I'm 30 years old now
you know I got here 20 years right mine
used to be really so perfect now they're
like two plums in a stock right and I
was looking down one day I thought
they'd throw in another what is the best
like two hot air balloons trying to get
away in the forest right and I thought
that's fascinating so I suppose this my
Zen moment not that I'm not happy and
it's real I preferred that they're
talking about their testicles
and are they excited it it ramps up in
an exponential way over here but if we
label this so it can handle this okay on
this rectangle that okay Mike and Ricky
I would say this you know a lot of
people say that uh uh but people with
your disposition perform remarkably well
on how one's the people who are most
nervous that people who doubt themselves
the most always seem to perform the best
this that'd be great advice if it wasn't
about being able to eat hot things on
camera I can't I can't use that in my
life you don't think I never thought I
could so I know that you're a long time
animal advocate pitas Person of the Year
and it's no mistake that we're eating
vegan ways today - what I have are some
bizarre interesting animal fun facts
there's a caveat though some of them are
too crazy to be true it's all going to
you the animal fun fact yet and then
tell me if you think it's true or false
during mating season male elephant seal
a map a harem of up to 50 female I'd say
that was I said it would still be true
true that one is true one for one Ricky
the largest spider in the world the
Goliath birdeater tarantula of South
America totally bro oh my god Ricky
Lauren I can't even finish because you
already know that it's false about as
big as my racket could be if the volume
to surface ratio gets too big they
wouldn't get enough oxygen so that's
pretty much the peak of the size they
can be I had a whole five foot six inch
fangs thing that I was going to go so I
just took the dimensions from that David
Arquette movie eight legged freaks and
then just tried to put it already know
you already know that's true Oh someone
who's fascinated animals throwing up
with that I've never lost a passion for
how amazing reality is and so I don't
need any anything other than reality
it's magical enough
hmm I can feel the sweetness before the
heat such a Norris you soon so you've
been roasting celebrities at the Golden
Globes that for years and it's clear
from the camera cutaways that some
Hollywood a-listers are better at being
goofed on than others has never boiled
over have you ever had any awkward faces
to face um I think nothing on so just
got back you know it wasn't a room full
of wounded soldiers these are the most
riveting that they've ended award you
know and these figures now if you see
people looking around wondering whether
they can laugh I'm not beholden to
anyone in that room nothing that's
important more and more now and I wonder
you know over the last five or six years
if you've seen a change in sensitivity
whether it's in room whether it's the
media whether it's the public how has it
changed over that time well what's
happened this year and is a reaction to
that startling free speech and
overpowering political correctness
people started thinking that they could
say I'm offended and we'll introduce
them about it you right hundred so what
now what you know justice your friend it
doesn't mean you're right people started
thinking not just that their opinion was
worth as much as an opinion which which
it is but people now think that their
opinion is worth as much as fact and
that's just not true it's just not true
and they get offended by that so they
say well I believe the earth is 5,000
years old you can't have an opinion
about how the [ __ ] earth is it's 4.6
billion years old read another book
don't just read the one [ __ ] book read
and return [ __ ] ball oh that I made
look lovely oh it's a kid is drink you
want the please person blue three yes
look he doesn't like it but our swimming
the deep end with me swimming the deep
end with me but there's a fanciest
prison slang ever mhm right okay
because if I'm still in a fun-filled
show that nothing can feel it right but
the by reacting I going I want to cry
but I don't know why I don't think I'm
mischaracterizing you when I say that
you sort of embraced your role as an
agitator but at the same time you're
somebody who does not suffer fools
easily and that can be kind of a
volatile combination on the Internet
I noticed that sometimes you'll engage
the goofballs and Twitter and at the
risk of encouraging more of the same
behavior can you tell me the types of
comments the things in your mentions
that bother you the most well some
people just want to say I'm here too
some people are so so tired and
frustrated that they're being ignored
they just want to they just want to get
in the way so I tweet something and
someone and someone gets involved
I didn't tweet at them it's like going
into a town centre and seeing a a notice
board and it says guitar Letham
and I'm going I don't want [ __ ]
guitar lesson although would it not
don't worry buy them just to move on
let's move on this wasn't to you
that totally resonates with me there are
so many people who dive into things that
they don't want to do or they don't want
to watch or they don't want to
experience and then complain about how
they don't want to experience those
fools and sometimes I'm like you had to
search this to find it you had to click
like forth yes to get here yet why you
all thought the worst that you are you
waiting it out yet you're following me
to read this to tell me you don't want
to read this that is a literal going on
so what's going on just still want to
speak you okay
thank you yeah come swim with me the
people are you ready to swim there more
yes zombie apocalypse and as the name
would imply or we're cranking things up
a little bit over here you have got
someone your xemnu between the cheek
this is not gonna lose we can switch we
can switch we can do whatever you want
our trust to
you've been such an eloquent defender of
atheism but it's interesting because
atheism you know no one's going to do a
crusade it's not like they're going to
send missionaries to spread the atheism
gospel most when these people are
totally fine and normal people they
believe in a God that I don't we say
religious fundamentalist it's a person
who believes the mad [ __ ] in the Bible
too but it's clear that you think that
the world would be a better place if
there are more easier well it's not to
do with being like they shouldn't even
be a word for a few of them there's not
a word for not believing in fairies
we're all these people being persecuted
you mean those no rapist baby a Satanist
John I mean right like whoa this is
atheism in a nutshell one person says
there's a God and thank you says can you
prove that with a note the eightieth
says I don't believe you that's it
that's all it is
you see if you took every holy book as
we holy book has ever been every
religious book every bitter spirituality
and hid them or destroyed them echoing
that went away and never right then you
took every science book and destroyed
that in a thousand years time those
science books would be back exactly the
same because the text would always turn
out the same right those religious book
will either never exist or they'd be
totally different because there's no
there's no test a little time to layer
some no it's just it's just in the soap
a face that one
the thing is with this is I yeah you
said you can buy it out at any time you
can how about but but finding out is not
tasting it in the first place
tasting it and then I can't buy it out
because it's in my bloodstream I think
that you're too deep at this point
you're already there you had a bite a
zombie apocalypse what's the bomb with a
bad-dog
what's Claire's make a duck sauce with
the grades who cares you're like Satan
[Music]
[ __ ] me that's really hot at the time
look that's ridiculous
I literally touched one bit of it that's
by far the highest so far yeah that
southern game I did not to do I don't
have to do I came here today going this
ridiculous I'm going to bail out I'm not
going to be entertainment for some
[ __ ] idiot on the internet I'm not
going to do this and then something
kicks in here goes I reckon up at the
window I reckon I could be declared the
greatest ever okay I really hope he
ain't about really really where you
heart
I wouldn't ah
the throw is too slowly I can take it in
the mouth no account no calm Oh [ __ ]
how that's really burning I'm not doing
there - I dragon by angry I'm angry at
myself
oh that's really hot man
nothing stop evil I'm Hughes I can't not
do it
I'm dumb and I can do anyway about
perfect
and I'm done I've done I can't do it
oh really ha
your love of cheese is well-documented
you once told Bon Apetit the only reason
I work out is to live longer so I can
eat more cheese and drink more wine let
me show you some cheese er I just want
to get your snap reaction from your
cheese days okay okay so I'm good yeah
all right laptop please this one is a
mature English cheddar yeah the kind
that you like is that your favorite it's
when I used to upload you know cheese
and on beans on toast it was always a
mature cheddar that one okay that's
classic
you ever had the Stilton the Stilton is
the greatest of all cheeses I think do
you like the smelly cheese's I don't
like that the really disgusting Jesus
now like some sort of serial killer
stalks do I rain anywhere they [ __ ] me
what happened in this room let's dim
this off the forensics because there's
there's been some sort of [ __ ] crime
in this cheez-it real men shake I know I
that looks a little bit sore I don't
know that sort of white creamy stuff I
though oh you want to see creamy here we
go as a sound bite in it camembert yeah
I know when I got fair mm-hm
I started working out that's ridiculous
I feels like a ton Chancellor they give
me the wrong tongue
so this is mad dog 357 very awkward I
kind of remembered on my answers I feel
because I was thinking about my tongues
gonna fall out can you make it look like
I was really articulate uh oh yeah yeah
it will be very nice to you in the anime
with hot food yeah
the feeling is is actually destroying
cells and if they're destroying
tastebuds and then you're the Science
Guy
well then your brain goes that [ __ ]
hurt then you release endorphins like a
saw like a morphine toxin yeah you're
kind of in taken a like high up yeah and
it would actually battle it'll get
addicted to lovely hot food because it's
the rush it's the rush that it's
anything to come down maybe that's why
this show so you're you're you're an
addict you're basically a heroin addict
that's what you dress like even trains
buying you don't think I look at okay no
you look good I'm joking I'm just now I
look [ __ ] I wasn't going to say that I
want alright now you an outfit outfit
yeah no I'll go no I'm going out there I
think you look beautiful Thanks one of
the more underappreciated parts of your
social media presence there are these
rap sing-alongs that you do you actually
hop on the beat in a way that's really
respectable are you a hip-hop fan you
remember how this all started
yeah yeah I remember the first um the
message by Grandmaster Flash so this is
amazing this is the future when you see
it at about 55 year old comedian Renfrew
Hampstead singing it on to two packs
it's a sight to behold and they met 50
cent oh yeah a couple of time oh yeah
what was that I was gone Rose wasn't it
yeah yeah in sir he was very nice and
I'm a JD at the time I met jay-z
licorice mine he was a friend yeah
Robert I met him again
um and his mine and he said oh I saw you
were in New York
oh I said I was going to come over say
hello that was words you wouldn't
remember me well your jay-z I'd film it
doesn't matter whether I remembered me
your [ __ ] jay-z yeah I like that's
actually like a pretty India
I think it has every reason to exactly
do that but it's so funny so yeah it was
very sweet Ricky cherry just have one
I'm gonna have one just to see what I
see a molecule would do so our back of
the show really yeah I'll get that I
juicing but I've got no taste in my
tongue now so I have to swallow it now I
have to any one of these sound bites is
really criminal tray this is proper mad
I mean I'm I don't know what to say
about it yeah yeah you can he really get
me oh yeah what do you make of all this
oh yeah I want you to make it so big you
do yeah so you don't have to do this
anymore
same with me I really I really want to
see you is like one of the biggest
entertainment in the world and just
happy and you in a restaurant going can
I have a little I've no I don't need any
hot sauce and and I'll be watching your
go I'll be watching over no I mean
that'll be a proud day for me too yeah I
think I just touched my eye I think I
just caught some on my finger
you're out I'm done I'm done I'm sorry
for you okay alright I'm gonna take a
bite and I have one more question for
you it was the most pressing one it's
the one that I'm most interested in okay
[Music]
so I love when you talk about Carl's
bald head you do these beautiful
eloquent descriptions of his bald head I
would be so honored if you gave me the
same privilege and how would you
describe my head is compared to karl
Pilkington but it's not as round he's
sort of like a little chump he's like a
little sort of shade sort of monkey
who's been allowed to I made this book
about human clothes on how much you look
a bit more I don't know you like leap
into something a little bit more scary
to not I mean really yeah yeah you look
a bit like much more sort of Street then
Karl it's a bit it's a bit cool a bit
tougher but I but I'm in trouble is
though because our keys car for so long
but
now I'm losing it I'm losing my hair it
looks okay now not bad look at this [ __ ]
yeah not a lot higher so voice is lovely
lies in a list right in an elevator but
with a light above it in the mirror it
looks like a [ __ ] x-ray when I wake
up in the morning I look like a baby
bird you know I mean where it's all over
and sort of wispy so that's going to be
buzzed off soon but I'm never really
having to wear a wig or anything I'm
just buzzed it off Ricky I made it
through you almost did and you did at
least sample on each one
yeah how are you feeling a little burnt
out there I feel okay because I drew
what I feel okay because I feel I really
held back and I was really careful
insensible I feel that in a way I've let
myself down I've let you down and I've
let the internet down but in a way
you're kind of the only winner here at
this table
I didn't vomit and [ __ ] myself on camera
which I suppose either and that's gotta
count for something
yeah little bit right there Cameron what
the hell camera lots of people know what
you have going on and you like would not
be an amazing that's the best review
this yet and so watch um David Brent
life on the road
exclusively on Netflix and streaming
from ten to February now watch it now
watch it watch it tonight life on the
road on them on Netflix lovely film and
it really wasn't very good with it and
you're fine on you you just didn't care
anymore what a Korean are what are you
going to do you find out man you just
keep it pushing you just move forward in
life
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend